[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did you learn about her passing you
know we would text each other and call
each other a lot and i knew when things
were different that
perhaps
uh if the the end was near
anyone that knew there
will always remember her as being one of
the nicest kindest giving caring person
they've ever met i'm gonna miss her a
lot
these are a couple of pictures that we
took as i left when i thought that i may
never see her again she was she was on a
walker at that time and as you can see
it's very very thin
she always had a smile on her face
she never felt sorry for herself i've
nev i never saw her get angry
or
grumpy or depressed jane seymour's
connection with olivia goes 40 years
deep
how is the family doing they all knew it
was going to happen for a very very very
very long time and nobody thought she'd
last as long as she did and that for
quite some time now she's been highly
medicated because of the pain and
everything so
everyone knew it was going to happen but
they all managed to see her
and say goodbye
former et correspondent lisa gibbons
forged her friendship after this
interview she did in 1988 at the santa
barbara ranch where olivia passed
yesterday at the age of 73. oranges you
want to pick me an orange oh yeah
when i saw her
not very long ago my husband and i went
and spent the weekend with them and
olivia's radiance was in full display
and her optimism she never gave up how
long have you known that
she was
transitioning i mean she's had
metastasized cancer i mean nobody lives
as long as she did
she was in so much pain
she wasn't so much pain i just
for some reason i think she chose to
keep living for a reason and i think she
wanted to make sure that chloe was okay
tributes for olivia who is expected to
have a state funeral in her native
australia have poured in since her death
from greece co-star john travolta your
impact was incredible nicole kidman in
keith urban's joint statement livy
brought the most divine light into the
world and kate hudson simply singing
for miss dion warwick the one thing
about olivia she will never forget her
voice
you once described her voice as crystal
this lady's voice
is crystal that's a good description it
really is what does that mean enduring
you know something that will last it was
time and she
i think got her life in order exactly
the way she wanted it peace integrity
dignity love
[Music]
you